it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week we get the massively
anticipated four on one monster mash
that is evolve current gen console
owners as well as PC get to fight it out
against the massive Goliath the slippery
Kraken and the murderous Wraith with
more monsters to be released in the
not-too-distant future you can play as
one of four hunters each with three
different classes and work together to
take down the vicious beasts or go solo
and kill them all whichever suits your
mood release your inner beast on
februari 10 also this week and Alcatraz
simulator escapes from early access with
the escapists modeling life of your
everyday prisoner you will eventually
acquire tools that will start your brain
switching into sleuth mode as you figure
out the best tactics to elude your
holding cell lots of various characters
and lots of different prisons means
maximum replayability so get a lot of
hours of play out of this pixel art
Prison Break game play The Shawshank
Redemption on the 13th this week 3ds
owners get the weirdest of links
adventures with Majora's Mask whether
you're playing this again after your
time on the n64 or your first for
handheld this dark and intriguing puzzle
solving adventure stands the test of
time play the end of the world over and
over again exploring dungeons and
meeting some of the most memorable
characters to ever come out of the Zelda
franchise play the song of time on the
13th but if you're really just trying to
focus on puzzles this week then maybe
try out unmechanical extended which is
making its way to current and last gen
playstation originally a student project
that found its way onto many platforms
this game has you controlling a mildly
creepy metal flying bot that makes its
way through the underground environment
flipping switches and moving gears in
search of freedom it's soothing robotic
soundtrack will keep you then as you
interact with all the environmental
puzzles and you'll easily sink a few
hours into this game without even
realizing it get down underground on the
11th
finally the beloved series Monster
Hunter sends its fourth game over the US
and Europe this week so we can finally
catch up on all the monster killing
action explore a lush environment
looking for beautiful fantastical
creatures and kill them
multi-directional wall-climbing has been
added as well as grabbing the monster to
strike and attacking in mid air to look
super badass this game will be released
right alongside the brand new Nintendo
3ds in all its glory get the monster
hunter game with the monster d s on the
13th for further details visit gamespot
com release states are based on retailer
listings and are always subject to
change see you next week